all right look
you too
and what you've done and you've built
and you're holding down from broadcast
tv what does that feel like to have that
pressure on your backs because
ain't a lot of loving left for broadcast
well you know i don't feel any pressure
at all you know i go to work uh knowing
how lucky i am
whenever we get together it's you know
old home week and it's it's great to
have a touchstone to go back to it's you
know it's nothing but pleasure for me
and you know
so as long as we keep telling good
stories it's gonna be all right it's
just been such an incredible experience
to collaborate with such incredible with
such incredible expertise i mean our
riders and our crew and we keep you know
pushing the envelope and uh digging
deeper and going harder and the thing
that i'm probably most proud of is that
every time we have a guest star or
anything they always say i just can't
believe you're still
committed after this long and we are all
so committed and that's a and that's a
joy what is also amazing like we say at
et these are forever jobs but this is a
forever job i mean you think about it
and you came back i mean you left but
you came back you know it's one of those
forever jobs isn't it the crew everybody
stay away from this
no he couldn't he couldn't stay away
from you that's what i'm saying yeah
okay
but what does it mean to have a job like
that that you know that you get to know
the crew you watch people grow their
families grow up you know yeah well you
know if you if you're looking for a
secure job i don't think acting is the
first go-to on the list there so look
you know to be an employed actor to be a
well-compensated actor and then to be
telling stories that you like with
people that you love
you know for as you say as long as we've
been doing it it's pretty special damn
right it's special and it's damn good
all right you're here presenting tonight
there is so much love for the streamers
you know you look at all the great shows
what are you watching
i'm watching succession
everybody is
severance
um i'm watching yellowstone
which is amazing right yeah chris riley
yes
and kevin costner severance uh ozark
atlanta
those are my go-to's yeah